una decisión responsable y valiente la
onu celebró la renovación de la tregua
entre el gobierno yemení y los rebeldes
su pies me gustaría anunciar que las
partes en conflicto han aceptado la
propuesta de naciones unidas- de renovar
la actual tregua en yemen por dos meses
más la tregua de este conflicto que se
ha prolongado por más de siete años
comenzó el 2 de abril y según ha dicho
la onu ha representado un cambio
significativo en la trayectoria de la
guerra las víctimas civiles se han
reducido significativamente según varias
ongs durante el primer mes el número de
muertos y heridos bajó en más del 50% y
los vuelos comerciales se han reanudado
tras años de cierre pero no todos son
celebraciones las partes enfrentadas se
han acusado en numerosas ocasiones de
violar el acuerdo sobre todo en la
ciudad sureña de taiz donde los útiles
han bloqueado varias provincias
controladas por el gobierno llamada las
carreteras que conducen a la ciudad de
taiz aún están cerradas mientras que la
onu se mantiene imparcial y no se atreve
a nombrar a la parte que obstaculiza el
proceso de levantamiento del sitio
detalles
los habitantes detalles ya no son
optimistas sobre la tregua ya no creen
en ella el conflicto en yemen estalló
cuando los rebeldes tomaron saná en 2014
y desde entonces la guerra ha dejado
cientos de miles de muertos y millones
de desplazados